mr. president Trump telling Republicans
to not be bullied into allowing
witnesses in the impeachment trial we
have just received a statement from the
lawyer for John Bolton about his
possible testimony also tonight
President Trump is celebrating another
political triumph the president signing
the new North American trade deal an
agreement he calls cutting-edge and
state-of-the-art it also was bipartisan
piece of legislation chief White House
correspondent John Roberts has the story
tonight live from the North Lawn team
John good evening to you Brett on the
USMC a it was a campaign promise that
the president's opponents even some of
his supporters didn't see a need for
back in 2016 but over the past three
years President Trump has steadily built
a case to dramatically rewrite the trade
relationship between the United States
Canada and Mexico and he sold it to
Congress with the backdrop of workers
and union leaders and corporate bigwigs
in the audience President Trump today
celebrated the biggest bipartisan win of
his presidency signing the u.s. MCA into
law everybody said this was a deal that
could not be done too complicated too
big couldn't be done we got it done the
president hadn't even put pen to paper
before House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
claimed credit for it we ought to make
vast improvement if we weren't we would
not have been able to pass the bill the
South Lawn ceremony was in part to draw
a contrast with the proceedings on
Capitol Hill the president thanking
Republican senators for their support I
want their vote also urging Republicans
to resist increasing pressure to call
witnesses in the Senate trial tweeting
this morning remember Republicans the
Democrats already had 17 witnesses we
were given none witnesses are up to the
house not up to the Senate
don't let the Dems play you today a
revelation regarding the number one
talked-about witness former national
security advisor John Bolton in a letter
from the NSC Bolden was told the
manuscript of his upcoming book appears
to contain significant amounts of
classified information some of it at the
top secret level Bolton is told the
manuscript may not be published or
otherwise disclosed without the deletion
of this classified information that
letter was sent January 23rd three days
later significant portions of the
manuscript were leaked to the New York
Times National Security Advisor Robert
O'Brien doubts it was leaked by anyone
under his charge I don't think the book
was leaked from the NSC I'm pretty
confident that well bolton claims in the
manuscript that he was very concerned
about the president's ukraine policy in
this interview from Radio Free Europe at
the end of August he appeared to show
none he and president Trump have already
spoken twice they were very warm and
cordial calls the success of Ukraine
maintaining its freedom its system of
representative government a free market
economy free of corruption and dealing
with the problems of the Donbass and the
Crimea are high priorities here
obviously but high priorities for the
United States as well the president
himself could be fueling the fire to
call Bolden today tearing a strip off
him on Twitter saying Bolton couldn't
get approved for ambassador to the UN
begged me for an on Senate approved job
mistakenly says Libyan model on TV and
many more mistakes of judgment gets
fired and goes out and immediately
writes a nasty and untrue book all
classified national security as you
mentioned Brett a few minutes ago we got
a statement from Bolton's attorney Chuck
Cooper who included in that statement a
response to the January 23rd letter from
the NSC this sent on January the 24th
about Bolton saying quote if he is
called to testify it seems certain that
he will be asked questions that will
elicit much of the information contained
in the chapter of his manuscript dealing
with his involvement in matters related
to Ukraine we do not believe that any of
that information could reasonably be
considered classified but given that
ambassador Bolton could be called to
testify as early as next week it is
imperative that we have the results of
your review of that chapter as soon as
possible and the statement Cooper says
he has heard nothing back from the NSC
on that request since Friday right tell
Robert sloughing North Lawn John